even very obvious things about this the
things which you think all that stuff
don't bother saying that because
everyone can see that I promise you that
even very obvious things will be useful
and interesting to us later okay so what
did you see anyone you want to start us
off yeah askim yeah it's a conical shape
isn't it okay now I know there's some if
you have a look at the glass you know
parts of at a sort of the outside is
coby but if you look quite closely if
you look at the inside of the glass if
you look very closely at about here
right you can see it actually it's very
it despite the curvature like this it
very closely matches a straight sort of
cone shape with a pointy bit at the top
it goes further in inside sort of the
shaft okay so good observation excellent
this will be very important to us other
observations come on tell me you saw
more than the fact there was a cone when
you I thought that okay all right water
level the water level rose we're going
to talk about that quite a bit actually
what else yes ok so the how can we can
we can we that's a that's exactly sure
can be set in anymore so seat away
because I was a little words you then I
do want some words words I'm wanted the
the rate of um what do you call it of hi
I'm increase my height increase
that rate they've got they got slower
didn't it the rate the rate slowed okay
all right anything else so so there you
go in a [ __ ] overflow good all right
anything else yeah yeah I tried I tried
um the pouring rate was I just put that
and the way that I was measuring it was
I was trying to watch I know this this
is not very scientific but I was trying
to watch the diameter of the water that
was flowing out that's the way that I
was measuring it okay initially I
thought about doing it by sound but as
you might have noticed that became an
increasingly less useful measure of how
quickly i was boring right okay was
there anything else that you think was
interesting any other things that you
saw hmm it's a nice little set I admit I
didn't get you to come out and have a
look at this thing but if you had to
estimate how wide do you think this is
roughly yes 20-24 I I measured it I
actually did go and measure it and I
measured it at I think the diameter was
26 centimeters 26 so pretty reasonable
guesses for the sake of simplicity for
the sake of simplicity I'm just going to
call it 24 because that's going to be
useful to me later on okay now that's
halls the thing how tall is it well
obviously you've got the height of the
whole thing don't you okay but what do
you think might be more useful to us
probably just the clone which ends
somewhere around here doesn't it okay
now you have a look at that this is this
okay first the top and compared to the
way I don't know what would you estimate
it's not as tall as the as the as it is
wide okay but again for simplicity to
help us think about this we delay later
on I am going to call it 24 ok I'm going
to call that bone height it's close
enough to 24 that up it's not a meeting
this kind of number to put on there but
it isn't 24 it will just make things a
little easier sneaker about later on ok
so what topic are we looking at today
we're sort of looking a super topic if
you like within which we're going to
focus on a few different things ok the
super topic is call applications of
calculus oops of calculus two thirds
internet visible to the physical world i
believe i just barely heard four
syllables in that ok now there's lots of
things underneath this the reason why
there are lots of things is because
calculus has many applications to the
physical world tons and tons and tons of
them in fact calculus was born out of
trying to understand the physical world
in particular things that change ok now
that makes the other first subtopic
underneath this this super topic related
rates of change a good place to start ok
now i do say start and i started with
this bread delivery is because mostly
when this is taught and when i've taught
it in the past we don't start with of
this we start with this and
mathematically I suppose that makes
sense because you have been working with
calculus for some time now right but I
wanted to get this in front of your eyes
so you could think about this and so
what we start doing some of this you'll
be able to fit these kinds of things
into that understanding rather than the
other way around ok because I think this
is all intuitive to us this makes sense
we pour water all the time maybe not
into gigantic line glasses bite we have
two sad the principles on which it works
whereas calculus very abstract ok and
it's a bit harder to understand ok
so let's think about the situation and
think about what kinds of things we know
that can help us understand it what's
going on okay so for instance the very
first thing with us was that it was a
comb right hmm it's a coat so why we
draw one it's for a cone there's a cone
okay now we've got some measurements
that I told you before okay which
measures will be most important well
we've got our a diameter okay but for
our purposes probably going to be more
useful to actually set a radius isn't it
okay so with a diameter of 24 we have a
radius of 12 centimeters or thereabout
okay now I've provided to the height of
the whole thing to be 24 okay there you
go great so I suppose if we wanted we
could work out what the volume of the
whole code is couldn't win what is the
volume of the whole code that's the line
of the cone it's a third PI R square egg
it's just like the cylinder with the
same dimensions but it's a third the
size okay so in this case what are we
looking at you've got a third PI R
square that's 144 times 24 what's that
equal to so something to calculate it in
4608 what's that um approximately I'd
like to get a number on them I'm
guessing it must be sort of in the 5 10
15 no yes no something else can someone
give us more acrid not
bird that [ __ ] 688 times 144 one Fox I
1115 to okay yeah that does sound like
it's better so we're looking at about
what in the 35 minutes when we got
what's the number equal to when you've a
bit 369 now what are all these units
they're all in a centimeters aren't
there I've got two of them here and I've
got one here see we're getting cubic
centimeters yes hmm let's see what that
right chemic centimeters about a three
liter container admittedly I did make it
a little bit bigger so I think we're in
the right ballpark okay for this
imagined cone that we have which is kind
of similar to this one okay